marys l'italie pays au monde le plus
endeuillé par la pandémie de coronavirus
a enregistré ce lundi de nouveaux signes
encourageants avec une augmentation de
seulement 4 % la hausse des nouveaux cas
positifs recensées n'a jamais été aussi
faible dans le pays
une diminution de moitié comparé à la
situation il ya quatre jours et quatre
fois moins si on remonte à deux semaines
[Musique]
le nombre d'événements respiratoire et
infection pour lesquels des véhicules de
secours ont été appelés en lombardie est
nettement réduit et même par rapport aux
jours autour des 14 15 mars
nous sommes à la moitié du nombre
d'interventions nécessaires dans la
région sous le territorie le ministère
italien de la santé a estimé lors d'une
réunion du comité scientifique et
technique que toutes les mesures de
confinement devrait être prolongée au
moins jusqu'à pâques n'ont rien manqué
nous pensons que le comportement qui a
été maintenue jusqu'à présent doit être
maintenue si nous sommes catégoriques
sur ce point nous ne devons pas baisser
nos gardes
si nous voulons vaincre le virus nul
devons rester à la maison
nous devons éviter les occasions de
contacts nous devons respecter les
règles de prudence qui ont été codifiées
dans les mesures gouvernementales avec
la chine et cuba la russie a été la
première à répondre aux appels à l'aide
de l'italie face aux coronavirus le
ministère russe de la défense a envoyé
par avion de transport militaire 8
brigade médicale venus avec des
équipements de désinfection et des
laboratoires de stérilisation 104
médecins ont été déployés à bergame en
lombardie région la plus sévèrement
touchée d'italie avec plus de quarante
deux mille personnes affectées par le
cos vie 19
une délégation qui comprend entre autres
des virologues et des épidémiologistes
les russes sont certainement spécialisés
dans ce domaine
les remercions vivement pour le soutien
qu'ils nous apportent en aidant nos
personnes âgées
giuseppe compter premier ministre
italien s'est entretenu ce lundi avec
donald trump
le président américain a annoncé que les
etats-unis allaient envoyer à l'italie
près de 100 millions de dollars de
fournitures médicales
on est